When we look at the world's skills,
one of the biggest sources of it is us
failing to do the right thing when it's
the harder thing to do,
giving into temptation,
giving into impulse,
giving into emotional sort of immediacy,
and the part of the brain that's most
central to whether or not that happens
is the frontal cortex most recently
evolved part of the brain.
We've got more of it proportionately or
more complexly than any other primate
species out there.
It's the part of the brain that does
impulse control,
longterm planning.
Emotional regulation does all the stuff
where it's the frontal cortex that
whispers in your ear saying,
do you really,
really want to do that right now?
I'm waiting to that.
You're going to regret it.
It seems like a great idea.
Frontal cortex about that.
Okay,
so when we look at our moments of life
where there's that enormous temptation
to do the impulsive thing and what's
going to determine whether the world
will be freed of impulsive horrors.
If only we can all get stronger frontal
cortices trained in childhood to be able
to hold out where you can have one
marshmallow right now,
but if you wait,
you can get to later and training from
early age so that your frontal cortex
has the most fabulous aerobic metabolism
ever and it could just make you and what
the studies suggest is at all sorts of
junctures of doing the harder thing.
Yeah,
having a really robust studly frontal
cortex may do you a lot of good there,
but when you do sort of the truly
difficult thing,
when you see people who are the ones who
run into the burning building to save
the child in their leap into the river
when everybody else was standing there
like headless chickens,
when you look at those people,
they're not doing it because they've got
the most amazing frontal cortex is on
earth.
That could reason through the longterm
consequences of,
oh,
what if nobody in society came to the
aid of strangers?
What they do is they do it
automatically.
You ask you ask anybody who does one of
these heroic acts.
What were you thinking when you jumped
in the river and the answer's always the
same.
I wasn't thinking before I knew it.
I had jumped in.
When we do our most amazingly like
wondrous altruistic acts,
it's not because we've got the most
incredible frontal cortex is on earth.
That could like reasons.
It's because it's out of the realm where
the frontal cortex and it's out of the
realm of temptation and limbic stuff.
We do the harder thing in a case like
that because for us it's not the harder
thing.
It's become automatic and that's where
you see it.
You see the best success with temptation
when it isn't attempting,
when it's automatic,
when we've distracted ourselves.
All of that frontal like work your way
through to the right decision gets you
only so far.
Fabulous.
Study this.
This was work by a guy at Harvard named
Josh Green,
who put people in a study in a brain
scanner of some task where if they got
it right,
they get a reward afterward,
and so there's an incentive to get it
right and this wonderful manipulative
setup where at various points people
were under the impression that there was
a glitch in the system and the computer
wasn't registering their answers.
So all they had to do was think what
their answer was and then tell you
afterward when they heard that the
correct answer had they had the right
answer or not.
In other words,
they could cheat.
And what you would see is it was a
random task and most of the time people
were having about a 50 slash 50 percent
success rate.
And along comes the opportunities to
cheat.
And if people's accuracy suddenly jumps
up at that point,
uh Ha.
That's how you detect a cheat or someone
who's long at that point.
So the question becomes what's going on
with the brains of people who cheated at
those opportunities?
And what you saw was as soon as that
active came up,
their frontal cortex is activated,
like mad.
They're wrestling with Satan,
they're wondering if they should do it
or not.
They're wondering if they should have
done it the last time when they were
honest.
They wondering if they're ever going to
their wrestling.
All of that.
Okay,
so that makes sense.
Then you look at the people who are
cheating,
opportunity or otherwise never cheat.
So what's going on in them,
and we've got the two models there.
One of willpower,
it's because they've got frontal cortex,
is that could chest like be be stoic and
calvinist and gumption out the Wazoo
there?
Or is it a state of grace?
They don't cheat because you don't
cheat.
And the prediction there is if it's all
about willpower,
as soon as the opportunity to cheat
comes up,
their frontal cortices are going to go
through the roof in terms of activity.
If it's a matter of grace,
whatever,
and it was a matter of grace.
The people who never cheated,
it wasn't because they had the strong,
strongest frontal cortex is it's because
you don't do that.
It was that simple.
It wasn't a temptation,
and that's much more of a model of.
It's not a realm of just having to work
so,
so hard to feel for somebody else or not
pocket that thing,
even though nobody's looking,
you just don't do that.
It's automatic.